data showing nevada has received the  second lowest number of vaccine doses  per capita  out of all states the state reporting  they've been in contact with the federal  government and the national governors  association  and they are working to address this  issue however they do say our state  officials are ordering all first doses  that are available to us  and ordering second doses as needed as  for nevada's strategy and ordering  second doses here it is  we are closely tracking when folks are  due for their second doses and we are  ordering  each week exactly the number of second  doses we will need for both moderna  and for the visor product those second  doses are allocated  and earmarked for nevada and are sitting  on the shelves waiting for us to order  them  ordering the exact number of doses she  says the state is having moderna  and pfizer handle the storage of those  second doses  until they are ready to order